la ferme de la tramblais a perdu 25% de
son chiffre d'affaires pendant le
confinement
alors qu'elle constatait un engouement
pour la consommation locale il y a
quelques mois
l'équipe a un objectif ne pas se faire
oublier
pour cela elle a notamment accueilli le
paris fermant consommer local fermiers
éventuellement bio c'est une action de
chacun et donc c'est chaque consommateur
qui viendra se rendre sur ce type
d'événement qui ira voir son producteur
local qui ce qui fera une action qui
fera en sorte que ce type de marché
continue de son espoir combler l'écart
avec ces chiffres de l'année dernière
pour son voisin de stand un viticulteur
les pertes sont considérables 60 à 70%
du chiffre d'affaires en moins pendant
le confinement
mais aujourd'hui l'heure est à
l'optimisme depuis le 11 mai il ya une
forte affluence dans ses caves de
pouvoir être là et dire aux gens banon
la vie continue il faut que la vie
continue il faut que les clients se
déplacent
il faut que les producteurs se déplace
il faut pas qu'on cède à la halle à
beurre etc
il faut qu'on soit prudent effectivement
il faut que des gestes barrières soient
respectés la vie continue et certains
producteurs voient leurs efforts pendant
le confinement récompensé 30% de la
nouvelle clientèle de ce marché continue
d'acheter sur les marchés ce qu'on peut
en ressentir ou a toujours autant de
monde
par contre avec une volonté de
de retrouver du producteur local donc on
a augmenté un petit peu nos paniers une
fête sur les sur les marchés on sent les
gens plus proche de revenir un peu vers
les producteurs
le mot d'ordre de cet événement
soutenez-nous près de 5000 personnes se
sont déplacées au premier pari fermier